Thanks again, everyone for being part of this course series, we hope you will learn a lot
from it.
And it will help you on your journey using Unreal.
In the course, we talked about their materials, we talked about its use case old ways, new
ways and material designer way.
We talked about material parameter collections, what is an NPC and setting it up, as well
as we looked at subsurface material and parallax control, creating a subsurface material,
the overview, unreal subsurface profile overview, some pro tips or look out for when working
with these materials, using the parallax occlusion, and material function, and up and coming
substrate, which I want you to be aware of and keep in mind, as it's evolving and
getting better, stronger, faster.
This is the new kid on the block.
And you'll see some of the limitations that I've listed in the slide deck.
But feel free to play with those if you want to, and you can really get some good
effects.
And we're also making it a lot more accommodating for stylization.
Well that's it with this series of courses, we hope you've enjoyed them.
And let us know how you're doing when it comes to building stuff in Unreal.
Thanks again.